hey everybody welcome to led live have
you ever seen a tragedy turn into an
absolute triumph find out on this
episode of
led live
light exposing darkness welcome back to
everybody we are blessed to have you
guys a part of our channel
thank you for stopping by and watching
uh you guys are gonna like today's show
i'm very excited to hear i
always love testimonies and so we have a
couple new guests on today
michael and drake uh michael's been on
her show uh uh a while back
and so you'll you'll see him again but
uh we're very excited to hear about your
personal testimony
but before we get into that we have a
few things that we would love to
share with you guys keith's gonna talk
about some of the things that our
ministry also is involved in
so one of the things that we like is
t-shirts we like to design them we like
to wear them
we're fortunate we can come to a job
where we can wear t-shirts and jeans
right now it's a little cold i wish i
had a hoodie but
you can check out this is one of our
t-shirt designs it's a play on stranger
things and it says saving grace and we
have many more so check us out on
teespring
and soon on our very own website you'll
be able to get them
direct from us yeah we do have things
that are available and not just t-shirts
right
we do we have all kinds of stuff on
teespring so as the weather is getting
colder we have long
sleeve shirts kind of like the one that
i'm wearing and uh
fanny packs yeah you can get any one of
our designs that's right if you want it
on a water bottle
that can be printed what else do we have
candy
yeah so i was in a thrift shop the other
day and you know what i saw
a bunch of dvd players for like less
than 10 bucks so those things are
clearly a thing of the past
we we actually buy them for our tvs that
are over here on the side here so
you've got a broken one you want to send
it to us we'll give you our address
so for those who still use dvd players
little live studios does have
all of our documentaries on dvd but for
those who don't
we also stream on vimeo those links will
be in the description below
awesome and uh maybe you guys have seen
the stickers on our water bottles
we have awesome stickers that you know
can just
promote your christianity wearing your
witness on a variety of various things
so some of these stickers are really
kind of fun and cool as you can see i've
put quite a few of them on my water
bottle and it gives you an opportunity
to talk about your favorite
that's right that's right keep little
light in front of you
and we also uh have uh another
venture that we'd like to highlight
video mission um
it creates uh christian stock media so
you know if you're youtubers like us or
you are creating things for your church
and you need some
jesus pictures or you need some uh
biblical illustrations
check out videomission.com they have
some awesome
awesome resources for you to use and and
very cost effective as well
so if you're putting together a
production and you don't have a huge
budget
check these guys out videomission.com
it's got a lot of cool resources
so patreon keeps these lights on
and keep us warm here and also help us
to keep putting free
videos on youtube so thank you so much
patreon and if you are not yet our
patreon family you can check out the
links
in the description below and you will
get an exclusive behind the scene
that we don't put on youtube so if you
want to see us
actually in action creating the content
that we do because we not only have this
youtube show we actually
create documentaries we do a lot of
various different things and so people
are always curious about what we do
behind the scenes and for those patreon
families we
get a chance to show you guys a little
bit about how this whole operation
happens
all right well without further ado i'd
like to
reintroduce michael bonanno he's been on
our show before
and drake drake what's your last name
davidson davidson okay drake davidson's
coming on the show
um these two have uh a really uh a neat
testimony to share with us today
um just a just an awesome story of of
how god can take something tragic
and actually transform it and flip it
around
and now you guys are actively involved
in using your talents for god so i'm
really excited to hear about this
and i'll turn it over to you thank you
um
so i was born uh
in april 12th of 96 and
uh two months later it was my father's
first father's day
i had a stroke so
that wasn't necessarily the best
father's day present a son could give
but um it did come with
a lot i lost all feeling on the right
side of my body
with the exception of some pressure
being able to be felt when i moved my
index or
fingers individually with the help of my
left hand
other than that no feeling and very
little motor skill whatsoever
nobody really liked that kid
he was a weird weirdo and
it bullied a lot it's sad when kids can
kind of be so mean
and you know you you see and hear about
these stories
and you don't realize like how much
damage that actually does
to a small person who is growing up they
didn't choose this lifestyle
this was you know given to you
just as just a as a as a faulty
propensity of life you know what i mean
and and here you have to deal with that
and and
you know it's sad that other kids don't
um or
you know i feel like it's the parents
job to teach your kids how to be
kind and loving and respectful to other
people that have
problems like that yeah well the
stroke obviously did a lot more than
just
being bullied there was a lot of medical
stuff that had to go into like
i had to get a blood transfusion and
it just i'm serious
up until last year i thought i could
never give blood but i just
recently found out i just had to wait a
year but
there was just non-stop blood
transfusions like you see
this little kid in this in the bed and
you're like oh he's just he's fine
but the way my dad tells me is like he
was crying as he had to hold me down for
them to put all the stuff
in me they were trying to give me blood
because i had lost a lot of blood it
affected the entire left side
of my brain i mean drake knows how
difficult
doing math in school was for me it was
just
it was tough i failed three times yes
just because having that problem
in the brain on the left side where all
the logic
and mathematics is i would black out if
i had to
push as hard as the rest of the people
the only reason i passed through high
school is because i had a scribe
somebody to tell me in the order of
pemdas
uh what i'm supposed to do so that i can
give them the answer
so the school wasn't really equipped to
to help no school really was equipped
the high school was a lot more equipped
than
where we went to school together but
nobody was fully prepared to deal with
this type of thing because
who hears of a stroke at the age of two
months old
you know like you know maybe later in
life
50s 60s but not two months old do they
know
what some of the reasons why i mean were
they able to kind of
give a reason that that maybe
potentially happened to you
no the the doctors have no clue i mean
if we wanted to spend a
a small fortune we could probably figure
it out but like
it was so long ago two months old i'm
24. there's like no point in
what happened then you know as long as i
eat healthy
and you know try to do my best to stay
away from any
uh stroke causing things i should not
have another stroke right
praise the lord nothing else bad has
occurred
that has hindered me in such a manner as
that one has
um but i had to go through pt
because of it there's that all right i'm
pretty sure that's an mri i'm not even
sure what that is
yeah but uh that's not the very
expensive
medical equipment something something
extremely
expensive but i had to go through pt
that's one of my pt's
these are all of my pets uh
except for the man that was my no-no
um which plays a
huge role later on because the last
things i ever said to him before
he died was not in your life when he
asked when he
consistently tells me like even here
he's telling me
uh use your right hand more use your
right hand more and the last thing they
ever said was not in your life
and then he died of a heart attack
shortly before
my nano's 50th wedding anniversary
wow so i kept that with me
for the longest time
like this little kid looks happy but
i i can tell you i wasn't kids were
throwing little metal toy cars
at me just to see if i would react
um they called me a robot because
what kid knows the difference between a
cyborg and a robot
you thought that cat the brace on my
right leg was
a a robotic leg um
and while i think about how funny that
is it was not funny for uh
the person experiencing it right yeah it
just it just wasn't
funny it wasn't kind and i just i went
through
all of school like that i was
i was beaten like everything that you
can imagine from a 90s sitcom think of
everything that you learned from uh how
bullies react and
act towards the the nerd
that was my life people think like oh
that's fake
you know that just that just happens in
hollywood no
i was table topped i was given swirlies
i was
pushed and shoved in lockers i had my
lunch money stolen
and this picture right here has me
falling because i was pushed down a
flight of stairs
and through a window like my entire
life was nothing but being pushed
down and i
i had tried to commit suicide and not to
interrupt you but how high was that
window that you got pushed out of
it was the second story okay wow
there's a second story luckily there
were bushes nothing bad happened
did the teacher do sorry did the teacher
do anything
no the the teachers did not do anything
when i was so fed up for a kid
mocking me and i finally stood up for
myself
i was i punched the kid over the table
and the teacher just looked at me
punching the kid and was like
don't stop on my account that kid's a
jerk wow
yeah i was gonna ask like did you get
like a window into the
perspective of your parents like what
they were
dealing with or how they wanted to
protect you but in certain instances
couldn't or
anything like that my dad always raised
me with this
um your disability
doesn't make you disabled um just
because you have
a disability doesn't mean you're not
capable of doing
everything that everybody else is
but there were a lot of programs
uh back home that allowed
you know a little bit extra help and so
my dad took
every opportunity to make sure that i
had that golden parachute
if um if anything were to happen
um so i
when i got to college bible college
before i went
to school with this guy i
got a free laptop by these people they
pay they paid some of my tuition
the other stuff was paid by a fundraiser
by a makeup company because they saw my
testimony
and just loved it i just
fought this whole time because my dad's
thought process was in my head i'm not
disabled
i will use it when it's necessary but
i'm i'm
not like everybody here
has two hands but it's to the point
where i find it weird that people
need two hands to do anything like when
i open this bottle i use my tooth
yeah it's amazing that god
has designed the human body to if you
have
a deficiency in one area how it
compensates over
compensates in another area like i just
love it that some of the most talented
people are like
either deaf or blind or you know and
they're just doing extraordinary things
where it's like you know we complain
that we can't get anything done
and you know we do have that the the the
easier time so to say
and so that just that just goes to prove
like you know
the human will is is extremely powerful
and yeah if you if you really sit down
and you go
there's no difference there's no
difference just because you have
a a you know less functioning
limb does not make you any less of a
human being it's just
it's and i totally relate to to um what
you
were saying about just the conversation
you and your parents had
you know i i went through something in
school as well and my mom
my mom's whole thing was like don't it's
all about perspective right don't view
your disability as a disability view it
as a superpower
why because just you having to interact
with the world differently
pushes your creativity it's like it
opens
a world view that literally no one else
can do that because they don't have that
experience so they don't have to do that
so just walking through through life
kind of gives you a upper hand in that
in that sense
and just pushes you to be more of an
outside of the box thinker
and i can kind of feel like as a as a
parent as a father you know what i mean
like you
your dad i kind of identify with your
dad it's like all of a sudden
you know your child has an issue and you
want to protect and to make sure
that you know everything is is okay just
because i was viewed
you know i viewed it not as a disability
i still viewed it as a
problem yeah and a pain growing up
because of all the bullying i was like
there is no god and if he is he's a jerk
like what kind of loving father gave
would give his
beloved children this to deal with
and you know like i didn't have
any friends period except for one and
the only reason he was my friend was
because
my dad and his dad were friends at the
age of 18. so like
here we are we're kind of forced to be
and when i was 16
that friend was like hey why don't you
come with me to
bible camp and like no
you're kidding me right like you know i
this this
god isn't real your god is not real
in any respect maybe it makes you happy
but
it it's he doesn't do anything for me he
if he's real he did this to me
and he's like come on come on um
now he wasn't totally devout either
uh he just wanted something to do on a
uh on a summer week nothing better to do
he enjoyed the people and um
he's like what if i gave you weed and
alcohol
and i was like fine i'll take that i'll
take that
and i got on that bus
after being pestered by the church they
were calling me non-stop they were like
hey
this is pastor blank this is that you
gotta come you gotta come you gotta come
and i'm like fine
i'll take you i'll take your deal and
i'll come to this
stupid camp and then
i get there and i start thinking about
no no
beca i mean i was coming down from high
i was hiding the entire bus ride
and i'm coming down and i'm thinking
about him i'm like
he's gone and i never i never did
anything that he the one thing he asked
me to do
was to use my right hand more and make
it stronger i never
never did and my friend knew
that i was upset about something he
heard
and in my voice that i was broken he's
like
what what are you thinking of and i told
him thinking of no
no and he's like can i pray for you i'm
like we're here you might as well
and so he prayed for a sign that nono
was with god that you know he's going to
heaven
and the next day
they have they called it mass but it's
not
they were not catholic they were
non-denominational but they called it
midnight mass
for whatever reason uh they debuted a
song
and it's called greater still you can
find it on youtube
you can find it on spotify but it was
the first long
time it ever was played ever and during
the bridge the pastor got up on stage
and said if you feel like you want some
prayer for anything in your life
we're going to extend this bridge and
you can come up for prayer and i was
like no
not even slightly this is i paid my day
i'm done
with this place why are you doing this
this just looks like a cult
because everybody is praising this thing
that doesn't exist
what is this and so i i just start to
walk out
and the youth pastor was in the prayer
line
i didn't know this until somebody who
was at the camp
later wrote a testimony of his own
for a college essay and in that college
essay
his testimony was mine from his
perspective and he said he saw the youth
pastor
in the prayer line run out to catch me
and he put his hand on my right shoulder
and he prayed
over my life that it would glorify god
whatever was ailing me emotionally or
spiritually that would just
lift it would go away and the second he
finished a cold sharp tingling went down
the right side of my body and i gained
eighty percent of my feeling back
after 16 years without any that's
amazing
and i didn't necessarily know what to do
about that
right like i was sitting next to my
friend i started hitting him like
what's going on and then the security is
like
this kid's hitting somebody what are you
doing and i kind of like babble out
what was supposed to happen and they
dragged me all the way around i
get up on stage at the end had the point
like they dragged me all the way to all
the leaders and
get me on stage who are you uh
my my name is michael bonanno and um
i had a stroke when i was two months old
i haven't had feeling until whoever that
guy is i don't know his name yet his
name is luke
like whoever that guy is he prayed over
me and i i'm feeling things
and i don't know what's going on wow and
um
so i got home and i was like
okay something happened i need to look
into it and i started looking into
every religion i don't know what like
every religion has a testimony has
testimonies like this what is supposed
to
be you know and so i i spent
the rest of the summer just non-stop
studying
all these religions and it just kind of
started narrowing it down when i started
looking at history and science and all
that and like
the only thing that stood all of it was
the bible and i was like
okay i guess this god was real this
whole time
and so i gave my life to him i
apologized
repented and then i went to bible
college because i don't know what else
to do anymore like i'm gonna give my
life
to god that's it i i i went through
bible college
for a degree in worship ministry and
then i was like
well i'm a musician i've been a rapper
since i was 14.
what am i supposed to do and i i was
i was talking with uh some of my dad's
nashville friends and
some other musicians and they're like go
to go to full sail university
and um i went to full sail
to give my first and best to god and my
music and that's where i met this guy
right here okay um and i will before you
go on with that do you think like
when when did you realize that your
question got answered remember
you asked uh god why like if you love
your people why are you doing something
like this
to one of your own yeah i don't think i
ever got like a
defense like it wasn't like when i got
my answer it wasn't like a definitive
uh i did this because or i allowed this
because
but rather you listen think reading
through the bible and seeing it
i um and looking back on it now this
entire time was just
a road to damascus moment because i was
i wasn't physically persecuting any
people of the way like paul
saul did but i i definitely
wasn't kind to anybody who was
and i would say that that was the moment
when
god opened my eyes why are you i am the
lord
christ why are you persecuting right
it's interesting you brought up
paul because as you were saying telling
your story i'm reminded of a passage
where
paul is pretty much talking with god and
saying man there's this thorn in my side
but as he's saying that he's actually
glorifying god for it because of how
close
he is drawn to god because of his
struggle is that something that you're
kind of experiencing
yeah i would say so um it was one of the
first things that i wrote when i
started writing christian hip-hop i i
wrote in the verse i wrote
um i can't remember the beginning part
of it
but the the final part was but like acts
9 8 i was blind from it all
the thorn in my side i praise god i hear
the call
something along those lines it didn't
matter to me
that's awesome yeah all right one more
question before i let you go i'm sorry
but um you were talking about this this
um
uh resistance you had to your nono like
you know i don't want to use my right
side and
all these things are you able to
identify where that block came from or
why you didn't want to
do all you could to kind of get that
mobility back
i think it was because having
this problem in my head i just
i didn't want any more disappointment
like i'm gonna work hard at this and i'm
not gonna get it
yeah like i'll work hard at things like
i actually care about
like i've had this my entire as far as i
can remember
maybe i may be seven when i'm saying you
know
no for the first time he died while i
was in middle school so it
lasted a long time because i'm saying
use your right hand more
but like you know i was like i'm not
going to work at something
that probably won't happen
that doesn't matter to me if it does or
not
because it just it's going to disappoint
me if i work hard for something like
this
and i don't get it
that kind of empowers that what we talk
about as christians that
human god connection how we can't do
anything in and of ourselves we need
that supernatural
supernatural being who loves us who
cares for us who would do anything
to save us when you put those two
together miracles happen
yes okay so enough for the interruption
you're going on with you guys met in
school
yeah we met at full sail university yeah
i wanted to go to california
god was like no no no no you're not
doing that you're going to florida
you're going to meet this kid that's
what happened
i'm very glad though that we got the
chance to
meet each other in florida i mean uh
just a little bit about myself
um i spent i started making music
whenever i was
13 and i was uh i was producing but then
i was rapping mainly because i couldn't
find anyone who would like to do
anything on my beads and that's fine
because my beads weren't up to snuff so
and
not to the nearest extent of what he
went through but in a way i did get
bullied through my high school for
uh releasing my music and showing them
that this is something that i'm
passionate about and of course
people don't see the vision until it
comes to fruition
right so um then i
went to college um i went to community
college for uh business
and i was just you know slacking around
my parents said
either go to college and get a job or
pay rent and live at the house or get
out
so i was like well mathematically
college is cheaper
for community college than it is for buy
paying rent or paying
rent for my parents so i just was in
community college failing classes doing
whatever
um then um i went on to some
troubling time for me oh i'm sorry and
during that whole entire process
i've been in and out of church um
i've never uh it's a renounce i never
threw away god i never threw away god
but i
but it was just more of i you know i was
working
i was working going to church and then
sometimes i wasn't and then it was just
like back and forth
and what i believe and what i don't
believe or whatever so
then uh you know so then uh
one relationship that i was in that it
was a long-term relationship
it you know fell apart and um i didn't
from i didn't do i didn't drink or do
drugs
i didn't drink until i was 21. and it
wasn't because i was like oh no it's bad
it just wasn't for me
and then when i was 22 and this
relationship ended i started doing
a lot of drugs and um once i
kept doing drugs though i realized that
nothing that this has
can help me move forward and i just
continue to pray and i just continue to
work at it
and i don't think that my situation is
any less of a miracle from god
than anyone else's situation but i know
since you mentioned doris i know that uh
god will open the door for me but i
gotta walk to it
and that means i gotta walk on hot coal
i gotta walk on thumbtacks i gotta walk
on legos
just to get in there barefoot just just
to get through that door but i'm willing
to do it once you show me that this door
is open
i'm willing to go and do the work for it
so
i applied for full sales saved up on my
money i moved and then i was
lucky enough to meet someone like this
um
the reason why we actually started
working a lot closer is because
one day i was talking to
uh some one of uh one of my friends uh
his name is uh kong and uh we had
uh we had a little disagreement because
i was showing him a little bit of music
and he was trying his best not to tell
me
anything negative and i really just wish
we would have told me the honesty so
that way i could get better
and um it wasn't even a disagreement
with kong it was a disagreement with a
woman and she thought that i was being
really mean to
toward kong and i understand that
sometimes i can be a little harsh
so asking if you know to tell him the
truth like be honest
yes what do you think about it what can
i let him fix
and then he just wasn't giving me that
that pushback that i really wanted
so then uh after we went into that whole
entire altercation i came outside
towards them was listening to what were
you listening to
it was a country song and i can't
remember
it it was either the name of the song or
the name of the album called
side a yeah pretty sure it was the album
yeah so
i came out and i asked him i was like
hey tarzan
am i mean i was like am i a mean person
and i was and i explained the situation
the same way and he was like i don't
know if you're mean i think you just
wanted
an answer and you didn't get that answer
and that's whenever you started pushing
back
um so then we ended up talking about
uh he ended up talking about a project
an idea he had
and this is over this is two years ago
because it would be september
2018. so when we started that yeah so he
mentioned how he wanted to work on this
project and i
for me personally i love to work on full
projects with uh
just doing all my production and all the
work for it because i think that's
really intimate with the artist or the
vocalist
it's this is what i'm giving you and
you're giving me something back on it
and then we're the only two people
working on it i understand that a lot of
people working on it could be a great
thing of course
but i think it's just something so much
more personal whenever you do it
so we spoke about it we spoke about what
we were going to do for the project and
i'm not going to spoil anything
of course but um we spoke about what we
were going to do for the project and
then as
time went on because full sail was a
beast of a school
you um we had we didn't have the time
that we were allowed it to
uh work on the project as much as we
wanted to but now since we graduated we
want to
get back we've been getting back to that
project and throughout school though we
were working on other audio projects
for school and just by using the other
stuff we were doing
as credit for the school even though
it's part of the ministry
yes exactly so but as far as what we
wanted to do
specifically we weren't able we wanted
to have the room to be able to
produce and make what we really wanted
to make um so then later on once we
graduated
i started working a little bit more
heavy on the project and
more and more and more and knowing that
even though
you might not you might not agree but
knowing that how much of a fan of
superheroes
that he is i understand that i came up
uh
he told me what he wanted as far as how
he wanted to
spread his message and spread what he
was doing and
i wanted the word of god yes and i
wanted to take it a step further because
i
know how much of a fan of a superhero he
is so
um i managed to at least for most of it
uh
i'm working on the other half now but i
managed to lay out this uh
pretty much the score of what a
superhero would go
what a superhero would go through what a
superhero would feel and then the
highest movements i really wanted to
make this feel
like a superhero movie i would make it
feel like a marvel movie not a dc movie
because no i'm just joking
they're both bad they're both great
so but i'm glad that i got to meet
someone like tarzan and even though i
might not had
the same struggles i still had a lot of
work i had to do within myself within
god and within learning
and i was and it's still at a point
where i read
every day i make sure that i spend time
in my bible every day
i pray all the time it's not even we
didn't start going to while we were in
florida we also started
we were yes we were going to a church uh
i don't want to i don't want to say
anything disrespectful but it was just
for me it was just a little bit
conflicting it was a little bit more
lenient there was a little more leniency
on
hate and just uh you know what i mean
and just
pushing people aside for something that
they are and i
for me personally i don't like that
because whenever i see tarzan i
understand this is who he
is and if i see someone else i
understand this is who they are
but when it comes to god and when it
comes to christ that mind can always
develop to be
useful for god and for christ so
whenever it was showing that this
is not useful just because of who they
are then that's whenever it started and
giving me a funny taste in my mouth and
that's
all and i understand because we're all
humans and we all have a different
point of view and that's why i love you
guys story of
i love coming i love comic books and i
love superhero
and your story of i hate comic books i
hate superheroes
but with you guys talking and having
that dialogue you guys managed to find a
common ground because
that's how god works well it's kind of
interesting you know like even just
looking
at how you know peter and even paul they
were just like you know
we aren't going to talk to anyone
outside of you know judaism
and they just had a particular view of
that
and god was like no no you know there's
got to go to the gentiles
yeah there's there's other people out
here that are my followers
and um you know i'm working with them as
well
yes and i see that's kind of like this
situation you know um sometimes
you know we have to be very careful with
with
uh you know going out and saying you
know you're not doing
what god wants you to do i mean this is
between you and god that you guys
really you know have to to at the end of
the day feel like hey look we labored
this before god we asked him
he's directing our paths he's working
through
us and you know i want to be
i want to be cautious of that at the
same time i still want to hold up
you know like you've got to like like
have that foundation
everything should be filtered through
that word of god and
um you know i want to encourage you guys
you know keep
out there witnessing i believe that time
is running out i believe that we are
ending
very quickly here and the world is just
uh
day by day changing getting crazier and
crazier
and i think that there will be a moment
that it is very difficult for us to work
and labor in the fields
in fact as the bible tells us so you
know um
we we need to do our due diligence now
and
and win as many souls as we can because
time people are needing to make those
choices
for in eternity and they do not realize
that eternity is literally at the edge
it's at the door right now and the great
thing about the work that you guys are
doing as well in this studio
is that you guys understand that certain
things
could be negative but then you can also
use them as tools as well
and i see how much you guys are using
these tools to move that message and
push that message
and then the best part about it is maybe
someone watching this video might not
catch it right away
but later down down the line whenever
they're walking and they see
something on the floor that's whatever
hit no makes sense
that light will flash on maybe they're
working toward it and this was just
helping
them get to that next step some people
it is just
the light switch flips on some people
it's the dimmer and you just gotta
you just gotta be patient about it and
that's okay too if it's
if that's who you are and i think you
guys do a great job
at helping both of you know keeping that
light switch on
and hope helping crank up that dimmer
let's let's go let's take a few steps
back here you know you get
you get awoken and converted back in
high school
yeah right you start feeling uh you
really want to use your gifts and your
talents for god and so like
in high school how did you how did you
kind of like use this new awakened
um faith started a club that was the
largest club in the entire school
district it was completely illegal
because of separation in church of
state uh we didn't have a teacher
teacher student liaison all we did was
talk about jesus
even though they don't like that and we
fixed an area of this
of the town that there was a lot of
drugs and
what we did was it was essentially just
we held church
at school um but i also
wrote scripts and made like short films
to explain what the message was going to
be about like i did one on depression
and i did
all this stuff now is this accepted in a
public school setting
absolutely not so absolutely so how did
people receive it how did the
how did the students receive well the
students kept coming
again we became the largest club in the
district wow that
a bunch of middle schoolers wanted to
add it into their clubs
and there was a teacher who was not
happy
not happy because she had the official
faith club
and mercy yeah she had the official
battle of the face
right yeah it was called the faith club
uh she tried to do the exact same thing
we were doing but because
she was a teacher she could get fired
for doing it
and she she came up to us and was like
how about this we dream voices and by
joining forces she means
take my people pretty much she wanted to
take all of her people and uh
have them as her own which would just
dwindle the
group anyway like we just wouldn't do
this and so
she brought it with like no she brought
it to the the school board
and the principal looks at her
and goes if you bring this to my
attention again
i'm firing you because we were doing so
much
for the school and so much for the
community
that i was like shutting us down would
mean
horror for everybody at this point and
so
it was funny uh we were trying to figure
out me and this kid
we were trying to figure out what is
is god doing before we got we she knew
we knew we she called the meeting
but we didn't know uh what it was gonna
end like
and and so we were like god lead us to a
scripture
something that would tell us what we're
going to do next
hebrews 11 33 like daniel
dot dot dot ellipsis you will shut the
mouths of lions and
scoffers and that that's what happened
we we shut the mouths of these people
who are trying to
shut us down and then you know we moved
into
taking care of the the food drives of
the town and
wow and we were off at 17 years old we
were offered land
the land of the place that we fixed
and then this was on for three
no for the last two years of high school
that's what
happened through it we we kept bringing
more people to god and what not
and then we uh get gave
reigns to the people who are coming up
after us and we were like
now you pass it on it went on for a
while
i'm not sure if it's still going it's
kind of hard to keep track of high
school when you're out for this long
um and then i went to bible college and
during bible college i was also
doing youth at a church on wednesday
nights
i was teaching kids on wednesday nights
and trying to work on music and then
after bible college
i went to full sail and then i just
that's
like i'm really serious when i say like
that was the switch because even though
i was like super christian up to this
point like that's when
you couldn't get me to shut up about god
it didn't
matter i'm not shutting up at this point
and so
i started working with um a organization
called better every day
and we were talking to schools and
whatnot about um
you know dealing with disabilities and
better ways to get through it
with christ like and all that stuff and
uh now we're working on this and
podcasts and
uh hopefully a a series ourselves
so kind of like when jesus healed the
man who had
you know the lame hand he was blind oh
he was blind
so many and he said you know
why is this done this is done to glorify
the son of man right
you think of a situation like this like
you have had this tragedy this terrible
thing that's happened to you that
that i mean you wouldn't wish this upon
anybody to be bullied and kicked down
and
you know hurt and but now you've taken
the situation
and you've you've glorified god with it
you've turned around and now you're
helping other people you've i've seen
videos where you've gone to
high schools and talked to them about
you know depression and
and you know things that you know
bowling and how to overcome those things
and how to deal with them
and and i think that's just so beautiful
that that here
you know you didn't just allow that to
define you
but now you're turning around and
blessing other people and that to me is
the very basis of what christianity is
all about right you should be a blessing
to those around you
and and to see somebody that's that's
used this tragedy and is now
actually helping other kids who have
gone through something like that have
you ever wondered that god allowed you
to have
something like this just so you could
ease the pain and suffering of some
other child that's going through the
same thing
it's brought up to my attention when i
started
this section of it teaching uh people
with these problems and and stuff but
like
prior to that no i was just like it's a
suit it's a super biblical style miracle
like the
in mark three he heals the man with the
lame hand and
that's what happened to me like that
that's like you're just going to think
bible when you think my testimony and
then this started i was like
this makes sense you know doing being a
christian rapper who talks to people
with
you know physical disabilities and
teaches them how to do stuff like
buttoning up your shirt with one hand or
you know um anything like this like it
wasn't in my head until then
and now the goal is uh
my two favorite verses luke 12 48 for
whom much has been given much more will
be required
and first peter 3 15 oh
in your hearts glor honor god and always
be ready and willing to give a defense
to anyone who asked for the reason for
the hope that is in you and do so with
loving
uh kindness and gentleness with with
respect
so if a uh if a 13 or 14 between 13 14
and 17 18 high school age person were to
come up to you
or even someone in college on fire for
the lord wanting to start something in
their school
a secular school let's put it at that
what advice would you give them
trust in the lord first pray
to know which way you're supposed to go
we didn't know what we were gonna do
we didn't know anything we straight up
opened
the bible and we're like what are you
gonna tell us and we we saw jeremiah 1
7 right it's uh do not say i am too
young
you'll go where i send you and do what i
tell you trust in the lord
pray about which area you're going to
focus on
and and don't fear the people that can
harm your ministry or harm you
but instead fear the one who even after
all that's done can still
sense his judgment because that's really
all it is
if you have skill and talent use it we
are to give our first and best to god
amen
amen awesome well thank you guys so much
for sharing your testimony with us
um i mean i imagine this is what
heaven's gonna be like right
walking around and just hearing how
everybody
dealt with this crazy life that we have
been given down here
and you know to be honest um i think
everybody struggles with something
right i mean there's there's nothing i
mean here at this table i'm sure we
could all
sit here for hours and talk about um the
different things that we had to
overcome in our lives and um
you know they may not be a physical
deformity but they could be some mental
things or
you know depression or whatever you know
that that that
everyone in life battles with and so
it's neat for me
and and i always like enjoy hearing when
god can turn something like this around
you guys are now
out there using your gifts using your
talents for god
and and winning souls and um
for those of you out there that are
watching um i mean think about this
you could be home thinking what am i
gonna do for god
like what could i possibly do i don't i
don't have this or that or i'm not
strong enough or old enough or big
enough or i don't have money or whatever
don't worry about any of that kind of
stuff god can take you from where you
are
and flip you into the most amazing soul
winner there is out there
i mean you know that that that's my
experience i
wanted to make movies for a living i
went to film school i i
that's that was my direct um
direction that i was like i don't want
to do anything else i didn't even have a
plan b
because i knew that this was the only
thing that i wanted to do and here god
has
taken that that gift and that talent
that i wanted to do and now all of a
sudden used it for him
and i use that creative process in
making videos
now to win souls and to help teach
people open up conversations about
topics that are difficult to talk about
so god can do that for each one
of you guys and i know that no matter
what field or
interest you have god has a plan to use
that gift and that talent
to expand his kingdom so we thank you
guys so much for joining and watching um
if you guys want to check out more of
these guys's ministry how can they get
in touch with you or find you
you can uh go to mbash3d.com
um there's a whole bunch of pages you
can find the first 37 episodes of one of
the podcasts
and a whole bunch of music that we've
done
um we also have a patreon patreon.commb3
is there a platform you're streaming or
what's the name of the podcast
uh the podcast that's currently on the
website is
agent blue okay there's also the coming
one
uh late night apologist where it's a
late night talk show type of feel that's
the one that we uh we kind of
uh recorded um
uh future episodes we'll have like
segments where we'll take
different things from different places
like if we wanted to talk about music
talk about biblical style music like
hymns or the um
what's it called chiastic structure as
opposed to
how we make music today maybe make some
music like that
that's a that's what you'll find on the
website
okay cool so check these guys out and
uh please keep them in your prayers um
and you know thank you so much for
watching our videos thank you for
keeping our ministry in your prayers
and for your constant support thank you
guys for tuning in we'll see you next
[Music]
friday
you